welcome to this video I'm playing
wargasm plate in before I have a zero
score zero all of to this always feels
like a there is room for improvement ok
let's go layin dogo Indian and in the
early again we also dashed out moves
like a machine the I mean they are not
saying he's cheating ever you know just
playing very quickly ok that's a fairly
typical position in this in this opening
line of the of the bogo let's see Bishop
here sometimes you can even yeah why not
just let's activate here Queen have six
there is 95 yeah that's not not a really
good idea but maybe I can keep the
bishop here ok can I go h5 something
like that or maybe maybe maybe just here
having 93 possibly ok he just he's one
of those guys who plays instantly all
the time
okay well okay this was the idea no use
in looking for anything fancy I to d5
p.m. I always have c62 to expel that
piece I wonder bishop to form entry okay
starting with the capture and now maybe
c6 night a form it's difficult to to not
play c6 in the long run because this is
seven point is always attended by the
night yeah I thought that night f4 would
be a quite quite an idea but he wants to
play nighty fried seems so if I go
Quincy Quincy five this 94 amongst
others
f-for i can probably take the sir this
is at least compensation oh come on why
not why not f4 Queen g3 is really
dangerous and here i have have some
attacking pieces which up g for bishop
h3 taking on c5 is not not really a
something to fear it feels it feels
fairly dangerous to me
hmm yeah I think this is tricky I mean
Bishop g4 Knight f3 a threatened to take
on default the right moment as well to
get rid of one of the defenders of f3 I
mean okay not not like now because there
are tricks with 96 check if it does my
move Bishop before ed 493 check Bishop
f3 Queen a three-night f6 check when's
the rook so I really need to to move my
CH bishop first like Bishop g4 what
sorry you can play a move like that in
the middle of of this attack really ok
yeah ok move this is normal looking
anyway I mean what else now so I can I
can might I might as well play it
quickly
or maybe it didn't find find find a
decent move or bishops III is just just
like in nothing moved from doing doing
really nothing ok here I can take I can
take here and play Knight f3
this is essentially a double a check on
e4 and Queen h1 so I don't really see a
defense my death reach yeah now then I'm
threatening Queen h1 which cannot cannot
really be a cannot really be prevented I
think night f2 but this looks really
precarious night queen age I'm sorry
night f4 and then Queen h4 is this is
this working in mrs. working Queen edge
form the other so that's working and
then create Royal 23 sss deadly or queen
h1 if you move the night so no defense I
think
I was really expecting them to play in
night F for now move 20 can yay someone
didn't didn't think that this this
attack was any dangerous and ended quite
clearly dangerous if our pieces are
placed on the King side it is it is
going to be dangerous it's just too many
attackers yeah not this one don't see a
defense here here there's this this
chick chat in quincy two main technique
there really was was was no defense
anymore i was i was really a bit shocked
that he when i played played here that
he didn't play Knight f4 simply to keep
pieces near the king and this this
should be quite ok ok well computer is
not agreeing interestingly enough before
concrete reasons the capture um I ok ok
ok I take that back so neither form is
it's not good because of this is very
concretely completely a problem or queen
f 6 h-6 moves like that ok then then I'm
already in good shape here because this
is dangerous I mean ok the computer is
quickly going on minus one yeah it is
just an attack I mean those two nights
there is Bishop the bishop coming this
is also participating so almost all my
pieces are are near the king and this
cannon can get ugly quickly yeah this is
probably losing bishops III but maybe
there is no move let's in fact the top
choice of the comp still being on on a
minus one squad but this means that he
believes saw it believes that serious
standard
fans yeah 92 interesting this this
shouldn't really check ok computer gives
this arcade once you sacrifice the
exchange yes okay this is this is of
course possible to avoid them the
immediate mate still good for black but
not not the medium and check and here
it's just it's just over at night and
force the right one okay so this was a
pretty good display of the Taking
Chances that this line is providing
especially if why this is somewhat
somewhat careless sir he really allowed
many pieces near the king but ok he
still could have defended but it wasn't
easy to do ok thanks for watching